yes well the jury here has just been
discharged here at Chester Crown Court
and they have a
been unable to come to a majority
decision on one count of rape and one
count of attempted rape however they
have returned not guilty uh verdict on
six counts of rape and one sexual
assaults against Benjamin Mendy the 28
year old Manchester City and footballer
and French International footballer are
also not guilty verdicts returned on
three counts of rape that's against
Louis Saha maturi who stood trial
alongside Benjamin Mendes and not guilty
on three counts of rape however the jury
also unable to come to a majority
decision on uh or undecided a
non-majority decision on three counts of
rape and three counts of sexual assault
the jury is saying that they felt they
would not come to a majority decision on
those remaining counts of rape and uh
and of attempted rape against
largely Gates Benjamin Mendy and the
judge in this case discharging them as
you say the crown prosecution service
now have seven days to decide uh whether
to go for a retrial on those counts that
the jury were unable to decide on that
of one count of attempted rape and one
of rape however Benjamin Mendy found not
guilty of six counts of rape and one of
sexual assaults on those charges which
relates to five women between 2018 and
2021.
all right Katarina thank you
um just want to ask you
um we've talked a little bit about what
happens next with regards to those
verdicts that have not been able to be
reached by majority just talk us through
a little bit more about the process what
happens there
well yes the crown prosecution service
saying that they will now take time to
decide whether to go for a re-trial
legally they have seven days to come
back with a decision however the defense
in this case saying that whatever the
verdict that Mr Mendy has had his life
his life has been changed as he knows it
his defense uh Barrister Eleanor laws
Casey's saying during the proceedings
here that the claims against Mr Mendy
were utterly ridiculous saying his life
as he knows it is over in football in
the UK and these accusations he will
never Escape describing the past four
months of the trial and the preceding
month for Mr Mendy as being absolute
hell and just to recap that he has been
found not guilty on six counts of rape
one of sexual assault but as as
repeating again that the jury has been
discharged after being unable to come to
a majority decision on one count of
attempted rape and another of rape that
is relating to two women and the crown
prosecution service now with those seven
days to decide whether to go for a
retrial on those counts against Mr Mendy
and on a further six counts three of
rape and three of sexual assault against
Louis Saha maturi a friend of Mr Mendy
that the prosecution during this trial
alleged works as a fixer bringing women
back to Mr Mendy's mansion in Cheshire
for After parties where the prosecution
allege that these attacks took place
both men throughout saying that any sex
with women was consensual at the crown
prosecution service now with seven days
to decide whether to go for a retrial on
those counts